First
that
Gravity initial gravity just your own
mass dropping without changing the
shape.
without changing the shape.
Watch that.
Not too far up.
Draws just like
Let the weight go on the front.
Let it go on the front.
Hang on.
Okay.
All right.
Let me
You're going to have to reflect, but
I'll demonstrate it now. Okay.
You could feel me pulling you,
but how much grip was I did I have? Can
you recolctly?
Okay, let's watch. You're going to watch
my grip. You're going to do exactly the
same thing, but you guys are focusing on
me. Okay.
Beautiful. Okay. How much?
Isn't that
getting stronger? Right.
Getting stronger.
Stronger.
You feel it? It feels almost like that,
but it's not. It's not there. Okay. So,
there's no grip at all right now. You
can feel it's not that he's pushing out.
You've seen people go, "Uh, oh, he's
he's pushing."
I can't remember who did that. I think
it was Ramsey Dwey.
Ramsey Dwey did something. So they were
like, "Well, he's pushing out and that's
why." But he's not pushing out
back against it. And you got strong. Put
it on your front foot.
You feel it? You feel that?
They so sticky.
Okay. So, we'll have you come up and you
can feel what I'm talking about
and you you could watch your reaction
too. Okay. So, when you felt it pull you
you went like that and then what was the
effect? You increase the adhesion
because the yong value is going up.
Okay.
I'm not hooking. I'm not doing this.
You saw his head move forward. You see?
And what you can see is the uh let's
let's do this. Which way is he leaning?
Do you think? Yes, cuz 4:00.
You're like going that way. Okay. Uh, so
which way do you think I'm taking you?
10:00. Do you understand? But you can
feel the adhesion.
You see? Okay. So yesterday
we were doing
this. Okay.
And we using spinal displacement
to look like you're pushing into me and
that's what made it stick. Do do you
understand? But I told you it's not
that. It's that I'm matching that yaw
value is what I'm doing. Okay. And then
it sticks.
I don't know why. I have the theory. I
know it works. I can feel it and I can
feel what it does to my mind. Okay?
And I can feel his mind as I'm doing it.
Like what's he what's he feeling that's
making him you know like Adam always
says makes him uncomfortable. I can feel
the tension. I can feel the reactionary
force to the experience. Okay. Um
but if I press harder into him, I go
over the yong value. I won't adhere and
I end up now losing the gravitational
force and I start using anatomical
things to manipulate the body. Okay.
What we're doing here in this drill
is
that force already exists in him. It
exists all the time. It's just so subtle
right now. You see? But if I match the
the yong aspect that this gravity this
descending force of his matter if I go
too much no too little no I just have to
match it.
There's the stick right here. Okay. I'm
just matching that.
There it says pull back on me.
And I'm going to fluctuate beyond value
and you'll feel
slippery
under it now. There's a sliding
stick
can go the other way too. So if I go
live but you can't go
you can't move.
Okay.
Understand? Okay.
So
what we want to do in this drill you can
use your grab. Okay. is not go pull
don't go like that you see what I'm
doing okay
as I feel him doing that from inside
my I'm vectoring this force onto my foot
under this foot okay not like this
he's pulling you'll see there's No
movement in my body. Meaning I'm not
doing this. Okay. And you you will be
able to feel that front. that front
foot. Okay. It probably feel like that.
Okay.
And I'll come around and guide you
there.
We're going to take their pulling force
and go down onto the front foot
by releasing.
If you go tense, your shoulders are
going to leverage over that fulcrum. The
foot becomes a fulcrum.
feel this is all it is just a force
exercise
revectoring the force to the front foot
making sure I don't tense so that the
gravity passes through me
there inertia passes through.
Virginia, you're going to grab
Yeah,
How much
again? How I stand?
She goes,
how are you now?
Okay,
so
No, none of that.
What I'm experiencing
as she pulls harder like she she makes
little jumps. Okay. And the jump
the line goes and the flexion comes then
the skill comes and release just like in
Zen. And then I but it's
instantaneously. Do you see? So the the
effect is the egoic mind. She pulls. I I
contest. But then the skill comes in.
Immediately it lets go. Okay. And so she
can't feel the pulsing. I can feel the
pulsing of the release. You got You
reacted. You release. You reacted. You
release. But she can't feel it. It's
just that it's that quick. Okay. Um but
she's now at the end like
she can go to 10, whatever. She can go
to 11. It's not going to move me. Okay.
But it's not going to I'm never going to
go like that. So what I'm going to do
what I want you to do is
don't brace.
You're just standing.
And you will she will operate slower,
even slower. Okay? So that when you feel
the triggering, oh, there it was. You're
going to drop that.
Okay? You got it? And you're going to
give them time to release. Okay? Because
that's the skill. The skill is the egoic
mind function in the dichotomy. She's
pulling me. Don't get pulled. And then
surrender to it. Release to it. Unself
to it. How how let the gravity if you
feel the gravity flowing through you and
you will get heavier. You see your mind
will drop too. Your body will drop.
You'll get heavier. Okay? That's just
the skill. All right? Let's try
to stop and train.
We want to feel the vertical gravity
working through us despite the lateral
gravity
working on us.
We have to feel the tissue drop just
like in zazen just like that last
exercise.
Watch your chin. Set yourself up for
success.
Once tension comes, release it.
Do it like twice in a row and then
switch rolls.
Okay. Any uh observations?
Yes. Yeah. So, and I always say this
like when when you come down to it, it's
really in a a skill at a sensibility.
Do you see? So, I'm just not I'm not
aware of the gravitational effect on me,
nor am I aware of my contesting of it.
Just like I'm not aware that I'm shoving
trying to shove down that elbow. I'm not
aware that there I should just let him
get up. You know what I mean? Um, so
yeah, there's a sensibility in it like
you can feel their pulse, you can feel
them get uncomfortable, right? You can
feel all that kind of stuff. Um, and so
concentrically the communion keeps
happening. Do you see the communion
keeps happening? I we become one. We're
not dichomous anymore. Okay? By how I
respond to it. All right? So
if you we do this again,
okay, and I this is what you're doing.
Everything looked a lot better. No one
was doing that kind of stuff. Okay. And
everyone was pulling harder. Would you
agree? Okay. So somehow it's it's
working. We have to address how don't go
back into the old institutional ways of
trying to understand this. Okay. But if
we pay attention
in this demonstration which seemed like
to come out of nowhere uh I am
generating that adhesion. There it is
right there. Right. Okay. And you can
see that when I move her, the whole
thing moves
versus when I pull her shoulder like
that. Do you see that? Okay. So, same
thing happens when she
is pulling when she's increasing the
force by what I'm doing.
There you go. Okay.
She has unified her mass in in what
we're doing.
Do you understand that? Okay. As long as
I accept what's happening to her body
and not try to pull it or anything like
that. Okay? Does that make sense? So,
the way I'm going to have you do this
one is you'll get to where you were
getting. Okay? Until you go, you can
Start to feel her center of gravity.
Okay, it's going. So, you can feel it.
And what I want you to do now is just
slowly move the center of gravity. I
moved it. Okay. From here, just pulling.
I do everything I was doing before. Only
thing I'm going to do is move that
center of gravity very slowly
toward the front.
Does that make sense? Okay, try
You can't come off of what you're doing.
If I
So, let's say uh we generate the energy.
Okay, there there's that. I feel his
unification and then I try I come out of
what I'm doing. Do you see what I'm
doing? You get what I'm saying here?
Okay. So, we we're here.
We generate.
And what I would recommend is that you
barely move this thing.
I'm barely moving it. That to me train
to to me actually trained. I I feel his
center already. Okay. I'm just
confirming it with the tiny bit of
movement. So tiny right there. Okay, you
understand? So don't you're not trying
to throw him like that. You saw how he
leaned. Okay, I'm just trying to that
force is on us.
We have communes and I'm just moving
that thing ever so tiny. See his head?
Okay.
Okay. Now let for for you
What will happen is
that when they feel that they they will
react again. That's what people do.
Okay? And if I keep what I'm doing, the
adhesion gets tighter. So watch the
watch that the the the
yong value got like higher as we go.
Okay? So
you might experience that. So meaning
that if I go and there's his yong value
and it triggers me, I'm going to lose
it. I'm going to link. Do you
understand? So his his increase as I
start to manipulate his center
should make feel that value getting
higher here. And that gives you the
center much easier as long as you don't
go into the reactionary cycle. Okay. So,
a couple things. I'm not going to stop
doing what I'm doing. And I won't try to
throw him. I'm just trying to feel it to
the point where I say training would be
just when you touch the center. You
don't even have to move him. We're only
moving to confirm that I was touching
his center. Okay? And in doing that
though, don't desire to throw him
because you're going to stop doing what
you were doing. You want to maintain the
feeling that you have
likely they'll feel like oh you're and
they'll tense.
Do not go and contest that ground that
the same way it'll actually increase the
adhesion and increase the effect on the
center. As long as you continue to do
what you were doing as if they went from
three to eight or whatever. Okay. All
right. Try Remember
the beginning is everything is dropping.
The original gravity is already working
through you.
Do not pull or you'll make a lever out
of your body. Do not tense. You'll have
to tense to pull.
That'll make a lever make you light.
Keep
releasing tension.
So, even though my the force is going
here, it's not that I get pulled off my
foot. Okay? Does that make sense? Okay.
All right. Let's do this now.
Okay.
So,
I'm I'm feeling the same thing as what
we would call the UK, but there's no
that's a dichotomy. Okay. So, I'm going
to feel the same thing on the pull.
Okay. So, as I'm pulling, I take his
mass, his gravity, his inertia, and I'm
putting it on the front foot. I'm
putting it on the front foot. I'll feel
his center,
and I'll move his center.
And I'm going to let you do a loose
grab, but you can tell ask tell him how
light I'm actually squeezing my fingers.
But I'll let you get some
material leverage here. Okay. So, I take
his mass
and I let that sink too.
Then I move that mass.
Okay. Got it. Okay. Try that trick. You
can have some finger grip. Just don't
death grip his forearm.
Keep your heel down.
So, here's my thing. Uh, Rio,
remember the drill started with my own
mass
dropping. Okay? So, when I go like this
and not doing the first the first part.
Okay. So, I'm over my base of support
and my own mass drops and I'm adding
their inertia to that mass dropping. So,
I know that I'm going to weight the
front foot, but I'm not going to
position myself off the back foot. Does
that make sense? Okay. Ground vectoring
is taking the gravity of the inertia and
moving it through my body to the
midfoot. It's not me
actually, you know, doing something like
I'm on the midfoot. Okay, does that make
sense? Okay. Uh let's do the next one.
Yeah, I'm the Okay, but I'm doing the
technique. Okay, so we go back to my
demonstration. I'm not going to grab
him. I'm going to get that energy.
It's going to be very light. You're not
going to be used to it. It's very light,
but it still won't move your center. You
see? Okay. So, I'm like normally, right?
We're like over here.
Move your center. Okay. So, likewise,
when we're over here, we're like move to
center. It's going to go into his
shoulders. So, it's very light. I'm not
I'm not allowed to use my grips at all.
Okay. But I'm pulling grounding his
inertia and then there's the center and
then I'm just moving.
Okay. All right. Try it.
Watch the thumb hooks.
Try to get rid of all hooking.
Get rid of the thumb hooks.
So, put your thumb with your other
fingers if you if you're not disciplined
enough.
Remember,
I can't be too light. I can't be too
heavy. So, follow the initial friction
and keep that friction. That's your
metric. Okay.
I want you to continue training, but as
you're the one being manipulated, I want
you to to notice that for some weird
reason, my elbows and shoulders
solidify. I'm not I'm not really
linking. Okay? Do you understand that?
Just observe it. Don't do anything to
it. Just observe it as they're doing
this.
as the person doing the drill. Try to
move less and less through space.
Remember the preface. Everything is
sinking. Everything is relaxing.
Okay.
So because it's force just so they can
see
I don't need the anat the anatomical
hooks you think. Okay you I can still
match the force with my fingertips. You
feel the pull the pull. It's not me
going like this and him going out. I
just that energy that's there. match it
and it'll generate the friction. Here's
the friction. And then we're going like
that. You get it? Okay. So, we're trying
to
confirm what we're doing, but we're also
making sure that we're not using
institutional explanations for what is
going on. The explanation I'm giving
you, this is the best one I can come up
with. Again, our end goal is not this.
Our end goal is what this does to our
consciousness. Okay. But
the explanation I use is the when the
yang value matches
because of the nature of the universe,
it treats it as one. Like you you have
the same yong value but you're one
thing. You see uh and to me that is what
it means. It's the the union the
communion. Okay. Doesn't mean harmony.
Harmony is still multiple things all
just blending together. It means
non-tuness is what I means. Okay. So hit
hit once. I don't I'm not doing
anything. I just do what I'm what I told
you to do. And then the universe goes I
think you guys are one. So when one of
you moves the the all of you moves.
Okay. That's what we're doing. And I'm
just doing my fingertips. Okay. Try it
again. As long as you match that yong
value between those two things, it will
solidify and commune. Just your
fingertips just like this. Look. Look.
That's what I was like,
right?
Your mass, their mass goes through the
ground, through you.
Don't be above or below that yong value.
The person with the fingertips is moving
the other person.
You're already off your back foot there,
Rio. Get your weight down.
Straighten your back. Your chest is
kicked. Fix your head.
Okay, we'll do one more which is easier
because the yong value will go up. Okay,
so we were doing this shiaku and then
the other shiaku is over here. Does
everyone understand that concept? Okay,
so you you'll feel yeah still fingertips
but you'll feel a higher value. So this
this value is pretty light but as I
start to go in that way it everything is
the same. You might find it easier that
see I went higher and that it's easier.
Again, it's not that I'm trying to shove
him. You can make a circle. You can make
a circle out of him.
I can go one way and pull him back the
other way. You see? Okay. So, just do
what I'm saying.
There's his mass. Match that and just
orient it outside his face of support.
Okay? And so what I want you to do is as
light as possible cuz the matching is
also me and him, right? So I I could be
this light.
Okay. So start playing with how light
you could do it, how small you could do
it, because that's going to tell you how
aware you are that I now have his tongen
and my tongen and his tongen is the same
tom. Okay. All right. Fine.
And again, what do you think you do as
what do you do as
neither assist nor resist? Don't do
anything. Just stay there. Okay.
Constantly go back just like in Zazen.
Your posture, gravity working through
you, releasing, dropping
Once you have a sense for it, start
moving it around all the different
angles. Send it one way, bring it back
the other way. Make it go in a circle.
Take their balance. Give it back to
them.
Do it as light as possible.
Change.
Always
return to you. Gravity works through
you. Always return to you. Just like in
careful that the the the desire to move
them isn't getting tension into your
body.
Take them just to the cusp of losing
their balance. Put them back. Circle
them all the angles.
Use your fingertips, not your palms. So,
I'm with my lesson. You're
hooking your thumbs and now you're using
your palms. Why we go to the palm? Why
we go to the fingertips,
Sean? Why are we going to the fingertips
and not the palms? The palms were too
tempting to No, I want the minimal
amount of material contact. Okay, just
do what we do. Go.
I want the lightest pressure as
possible. I want subtle subtle forces.
Do it with one fingertips.
Watch for all your crutches that you're
trying to do. Am I trying to push in
against them?
Looks like a lot of pressure on the
side. Virginia.
[Music]
Okay.
So again,
see that? See that thumb joint hook
ledge? That's that's a crutch.
That's no different than this.
My palm more. I got more friction.
How light. I'm going to I'm going to try
to improve myself. I see how like
there's the P. There's your reaction to
it.
Okay. All right. So, that's what we're
doing now. We're going to play with it.
And to play with it, we have we're going
to risk failing. Okay. And we're going
to observe ourselves for all the
crutches that we're doing because we
can't
get here. What do I always return to?
Me. Me. Release. Okay. Try it again.
If there's a threeman team, you can just
cycle in
something new. We'll try
Don't put the thumbs.
always return to you.
Release your tension. Feel
your tissue dropping.
Careful of the desire.
Okay.
In my
poetics, what generated the adhesion?
What that say?
You're matching the y value. Then then
the universe treats it as one.
Is it is that at all relevant to
whether the yong value is being done
with this finger or this finger or both
fingers?
What about my palm? No. Me grabbing him,
him grabbing me. No. Could I do it with
my head? Yes. You see? Okay. So, we go
back now and he's gonna go to the palm
position. Okay.
Um, and I've got his back on me. So,
let's let's keep it where we just have
flat. I am doing it now. There's a pull.
Okay. So, inside his grip I There it is.
Right there. and then move. Okay, you
got it. I'm not again I'm not doing that
if you get stuck. It's just you already
did it with fingertips. There's more
yong here and you'll feel it right away.
Just stick at that value and you will
then he will work and it'll move. Okay,
try.
So his palms are in but not his fingers.
Don't give him ledges.
Just get your palms on him. Don't give
him tough ledges.
Take take that energy.
No ledges. Okay. You understand? You're
like trying to go like that. Okay. I'm
going this way. Which way you feeling?
You're going forward. You see? So, I'm
going to There's a yawn value and I'm
going to increase the value.
Do you understand? Okay. So, I'm going
this way. It got really sticky right
now. And once it's sticky, then I can.
Okay. Try that.
That's it.
Don't rotate.
and take him to the shikaku.
Over the outside of the front foot is
not shikaku.
Watch I do my body drops and I'm going
to shift using the front foot. I
shifting weight this way.
This way.
Get him moving. There's the pull. Get
him moving. Shifting.
Okay. Here. Here. Try.
Press down into the front foot. Bring
weight onto the back foot. They come
with me.
Bring him with you.
Shift onto the back leg.
Bring them with you.
[Music]
Let's get our elbow articulation back to
you're doing your bicep stuff.
Keep your structure. Don't let them pull
your shoulders as you're going back.
Keep that structure.
Okay, this one's a little different.
Okay, no ledges for me. Okay, I'm here
and I'm not I'm not going to turn him
this one. I'm just bringing them in.
You're not pushing.
Don't push. You're not supposed to push
in this. Okay. He's there. You can pull
if you want.
Got increased the adhesion.
That's what I'm doing. Okay. Try.
Does everyone understand? Yeah. We
normally spin the display. So there's
not in any of this. We're not finally
displacing any of this. Okay.
is not doing anything. He's just
standing there.
Shift your weight. Don't drop your
elbows. Just shift your weight.
You're just bringing them straight in.
So make sure you're at
okay both of you. So partially if your
if your arm is bent so let's bend your
elbows like the T- reps people. Okay.
And I bend my elbows. Look at the chest
range. That should have never happened.
Okay. So, kata is not only
energetically, anatomically correct, but
kat is giving you Yeah. That is where
better start happening.
Do the T-Rex
like that. And then I do the T-Rex.
That's giving you a bad habit. That
should freak you out. Okay. So, the
other is happening when she's doing
T-Rex. I do T-Rex go. Then I can just do
that. You see that? And it's
complicating things. It's when when you
have the skill, that doesn't matter. But
right now, it's complicating things. And
we're learning a bad habit. So she's in
I'm in. See the chest range? I don't do
anything. So she's now going. Don't use
the ledge. You feel that ledge? Just use
the friction on the side. Don't go out.
Don't go out.
You want that front. You want that. You
want my grounding foot. That's going to
increase the value. You have to want it.
Okay. All right.
You guys don't hit each other enough in
your dojo. That's why you have those
little T-Rex arms.
Okay.
Um,
Now we have to do
actual.
She's still not pushing. She's there.
There is a ledge. I don't use the ledge.
I use the adhesion.
I just did it.
You see she's grabbing. I don't use the
ledge.
I use the adhesion of the palm. I
You will feel her ledge because she's
reacting to the pull. She'll ledge on
me. I still don't start manipulating the
ledge. I want to keep the center. Okay?
So, what I mean so you understand this
is what you did. Okay? So, there's my
there's my grip. You start to move me
the thumb pressure. You see? Okay.
Again, you try. I want you to do
nothing. This is all I want. This is the
feeling I have right now. Okay, that's
what I do. You go. I keep that feeling.
You don't ever feel my thumb. Okay. All
right. Try it. But if they do that, you
don't contest on it and try to leverage
on it. Okay. You stay with the adhesion
in the palm. Why would I say that
partially?
What do you think's going to happen if
you go and
trying to out leverage the le their
lever the stronger opponent will just
not let you what about their shoulder
their shoulder and elbow adhesion
their solidification do you it's going
to go away so you start linking them
that's what's going to happen you were
with the center the whole time and
you're going to stay with the center
you're not you don't want to go into the
elbows or the shoulders okay try it
again
You are always feeling your wrist in
their palm.
your wrist in their palm.
Stay out of their joints.
Watch the T-Rex arm.
You have to always return to you and
release the tension in you.
Watch the desire to pull them and the
unconscious tension it brings.
Okay. So go on.
We're going to do the hands attention.
Okay. So again, he's not doing anything.
He's just there.
I am going to not pull on his fingers,
not fulcrum on his thumb. I'm in that
palm area. Okay. So the earth hand,
that's what I use here. It's no
different. He's open his hand. There's a
cushion. Okay. Even though those are
there, I'm here. Okay. And I'm still
moving that center. Yes, his Yes, his
elbow's going to move, but I don't want
to just move his length, his shoulder
joints, and all that. Okay, I'm moving
the the center.
That means leave it open. Okay, that's
the same thing.
close. You should feel exactly the same.
In other words, I should feel the same.
He might like he is reacting to it by
grabbing harder. Okay, I might do that.
I don't start pulling on it. I stay with
that and capitalize upon the fact that
Thank you. That made it easier to move
you on. Okay. So, let's try the first
hand.
They're still not pushing.
Wrist to palm.
Keep your posture.
Move the center.
You're peeling off his palm.
You're peeling off his palm. So you must
be prying against his fingers. So if he
opens his hand, that feeling should be
the same.
You connect to his center. That's it.
Now he closes his fingers. Same side,
please. And it doesn't change you.
You're still in the palm.
Moving that center, feeling the center.
Moving the center.
very hard. You get pulled by it.
Again,
don't do your tension. Just do what
we're doing here.
[Music]
Okay.
So, careful of all the ways that we've
been taught to get a mechanical
advantage. So, right, bring your elbows
close,
get over the top.
that
we were doing things with fingertips.
Okay? So, don't don't try to get
leverage on this. Don't seek a
mechanical advantage. You're just here
and I'm moving in that center. That's
all I'm doing. Now, I'm moving it with
this shape. I'm still moving in the
center.
Okay? So, that's why I'm saying like
don't do your tension because you
probably were taught seek mechanical den
and we don't want a mechanical den
because that's a material anatomical
leveraging we're going to use the forces
so we're using the gra the gravity to
move him okay does that make sense okay
so try same drill we're just in familiar
territory but we have to make it
unfamiliar go
All inertia, gravity goes down.
You match the yong value.
Don't peel that fingers anymore, Andrew,
because you're peeling off of the palm.
Just move the palm.
Don't peel. Don't peel. Do you
understand what I'm saying? Can you feel
that? When you Okay. So, this is what
Virginia was doing. We'll have you come
closer so you can see this. Okay. He he
he is so used to getting on the other
side of the axis of rotation. You see
that he starts to curl that and when he
does that he's he's making space here
but he has to match the value. Okay. And
so it's a different way. Does my hand
curl? Yes. But if you pay attention it
never curls first. It moves his center
first.
Do you understand? is that palm is
moving and as he moves in order now that
he is uh deeper into this there's that
little space again and you could push
push into that palm with that curl now.
So you're here.
Okay.
Isn't what we usually do. You're going
to grab my friend
and you go like that. Okay. Does does my
hand do that shape? Yes.
But it's not what's getting me there.
There's the space.
Instead, I stay on the palm.
You see? Now, if I stay here, I can't
move him anymore.
But if I now turn,
you see how I'm doing that? And that's
what's making my hand turn. as as he
moves and his hand gets over. It's go
his hand is turning and I'm staying with
it. It's not me turning his hand
as he's as he's moving
I will eventually
this angle here where is in order to
keep the adhesion I had to turn my hand
he turned his hand. Do you understand
that? So again it says say it's the it's
the problem of do I move him? No. Move
yourself. Am I making something happen
to him? No, I'm not making something
happen to him. Okay, I'm staying with
him. Am I throwing him with that hand?
No, that hand is staying with him. Same
exact thing here. Okay, try it.
Prioritize the adhesion.
So don't prematurely curl your hand.
Don't prematurely curl your hand, Rio.
Keep that wrist to palm pressure and
keep it even as he's moving.
Need to move him more to your to your
left before you get that much curl. See
how it's coming out?
Send everything down. You're prying
through his fingers.
Just like I just like I do here. That
That's There's the center. Okay. In this
case, I'm moving it. this way. Okay.
So, I move that and I keep this
pressure.
And as you start to move
that way, you see how it is angled up
like that?
That is when you would have to curl it
in order to keep that same relationship
because when his elbow goes in the the
wrist turn. So you you can't leave your
wrist here and turn your elbow in. You
see that? You turn your elbow in the
wrist turns. That's where my hand turns.
Okay. So go over here.
This is where my hand turns. And only to
that degree. I didn't do a form. You see
that? This is where it always goes.
Okay. I'm prioritizing the adhesion
inside the palm. Okay. Again, why?
Because he moves as a unit. I'm not
linking him. Okay. Try it again.
Don't do a form, do a feeling.
Don't curl for no reason. You're
following their palm.
Watch the T-Rex.
Don't curl for no reason.
Watch your posture.
All right. I think we reach that ceiling
there for a lot of people. But again, we
were doing it. Now we just have a form.
I can't let go of the form. Okay. So
we'll work on it. We'll work on other
stuff here. Okay. So we're here going
and there's a end to this. There's no
more effect on it. You see
this movement.
You're you're not doing anything. I
pull. Will you pull? Pull. Okay. So I am
moving
and now in order to do something here. I
have to do something weird. Do you get
it? I can't do my shapes.
That means that from here it's a yong
phase and it's starting to go into the
yin phase. Got that? As it goes into the
yin phase, I don't try to extend the
yong phase. I go to the next movement.
So, as I'm going here, that's where it
drops. Okay.
I'm having Andrew pull because he's
doing weird stuff. Okay, on here I feel
I got got light adhesion is lightening
up. Okay, as it's lightening up I to
keep the same feeling. I'm doing this
again. I am doing this here.
I am not trying to leverage. Not trying
to leverage. Do you understand? I keep
that feeling.
It's getting light. There's that
feeling.
Understand? Okay. Let's take the fingers
away and give a little pulling pressure
cuz you're culturally so trained to walk
in
No matter how many hours we're doing
where we're just standing still.
Slight pull. Just a slight pull. Not a
huge pull.
You got to bring him forward. We have to
go to the full
yin part.
without pulling
because you lean, you don't move. So,
okay,
if you're going like this and you move
towards him, The energy is not going
that way. You you're going like that. So
you're over here. I'm going to move his
center.
Now feel feel that that way. Okay. But
look what happens when I go like that.
It comes off. That's what you're doing.
Okay. So again, I have videos of Chiba
doing this stuff. Okay. No. Move him.
Move him. It's still working. You see
it's not yin yet. Keep moving him. Then
his skin.
Okay, try it again.
You have to do full yong. You were
going, you were taking off.
Careful. You're leaning forward. Same
same correction.
Follow the ceiling.
in the palm but
okay and now I pull.
You understand?
I keep the feeling
feeling. Stay there. You're going to
feel this. There's the adhesion.
This is contest.
[Music]
You see the difference? Yes. Okay. Try
it.
Keep the feeling in the wrist.
And you're chasing a feeling, not a
form.
You want to go down because his
resistance
is
going in.
Does everyone understand that? So when
you're here like this and you're going
back, his resistance was going that way.
You just did a yamong clash. What you
want to do is we're here is he's going
that way. You don't go that way. He's
going that way. You're just going down
90 to that angle. Okay. Go.
Don't pull out.
Now chapter
round
changes.
Don't do it.
Why do you lean like that?
What was what? How did all this start?
Your energy is descending down.
Gravity's working through you. Rio,
don't take so much weight onto your
front foot that it take you off your
back foot. Chris, stop leaning forward
like that. You're not You're getting y
energy in there. And then what do you
do? Okay. Weird. Okay. Try it again.
down.
[Music]
Don't pull.
So remember how the body
comes in,
gets at this angle. Remember that. Okay.
goes around,
comes back.
My hand
doing the exact same thing.
That's not it. That's trying to shove
him down. Okay. Boom.
Just like yesterday,
you can do the whole move without any
footwork. I can't do this whole move
without any footwork.
Okay, try it.
If if your footwork is making you do
tension on it,
don't do the footwork.
Do the feeling. Do the drill. Adhere to
the palm.
You're going back. That's not the
pattern.
Got to use circles.
See if he's not he's not far enough.
Here's what you're doing.
like here. Now,
what's that? That does the material
leveraging and it's the skin suit pull.
Okay. So, I have to wait till
I feel there's no more yong on it.
There's a lot of yong on it.
You got it. Do you understand? I have to
wait.
Then my hand can just with his own
weight do it. Okay.
What you're doing is yong yong. You have
to pass through.
[Music]
Pull. Pull. Pull.
You stop. You little coward.
Good
that pull. Yes. So why did the one
before that work? It looked like it
worked. What did I call you? Power. Why
did So why did it work? Cuz I Cuz he
stopped coming forward
and I could do that. You get it? Right.
Same thing like why did why did tension
not get work? Cuz you didn't come in.
You know the choreograph cuz you didn't
come in when we just came in. All of a
sudden we're bouncing off. Okay. Does
that make sense? Okay. So
one pull looked like it worked because
you reconciled it. Okay. When I made you
come in,
then it was like that is not going to
work. Okay? Unless I'm way stronger than
you. So,
you have to stop doing that. You have to
feel.
Don't do anything. You're doing
something
there. So, look at the difference. Watch
the feeling. Do what you doing.
You see? Feel that. Do that again. Feel
the pressure in the palm.
Don't do anything.
Immediately more pressure. You see that?
So, don't do anything. Don't do
anything. Neither assist nor resist.
Okay. Try it again.
It's not a hard fall.
Just feels hard because you're not in
control.
[Music]
round the corner
then down to his angle.
That's better.
You're leaning forward.
Bring him more forward.
The center has to you.
[Music]
Let's switch everyone.
Turn over. It's taking you so long.
Change everyone. No. No. He has. You
have more ability there. Okay. Then
round that corner back towards yourself.
Then down. That's it.
With the adhesion,
not the thumb leverage.
His center's not pass you.
The center has to pass you for this
spiral to work.
Don't pull out. You should feel your
outer deltoid, all that. That's telling
you I'm not doing it.
And again,
don't smell.
This is why I go backwards. Do Do you
understand that? Okay. All right.
There's the earth hand.
Heaven hand. It's the same thing
with inside the grip. With inside
Don't hook. Don't hook things. It'll go
his elbow
again. Leave the footwork out.
Okay, try it.
Start with open palm.
Open palm.
Uh, it's your back hand.
Now,
change stance, Chris.
Use your right hand. Right. That's it.
Find the center.
Open palm.
Move the center with the friction in the
palm.
Don't do tension. Just do the feeling.
And don't do anything you can. Don't do
anything. Don't take any you can. Don't
turn your center. Don't do anything.
No one's throwing you.
It's nice at the beginning,
but
It
see
pressure
I let your momentum do it. This I don't
want to ever let your momentum do it. I
don't contest the momentum, but
especially in this drill, I keep the
pressure. The pressure
is the same.
Same way though, I don't want to go over
pressure. Pressure increase. Okay, try
it again.
Don't do tension.
My arm did not come forward.
Don't come forward.
Don't turn. Don't do anything. Don't
bring tension into you. You're just a
barbell right now.
[Music]
Come up. Come up. Don't come back. We're
not coming back. I'll demonstrate it
again. So, okay, I'll give you my
perception of what's going on. I can
barely get you into the drill.
If you pay attention, there's a lot of
repetition.
There's some insults. There's Jesus
fought. We can't do the drill.
When did that start?
When we got to Tension.
You won't let go. That was last night's
talk. Okay? And the a lot of the
repetitions are just do the feeling.
Just do the feeling. Don't do tension.
So something as obvious as just note
what my hand is doing in space.
You see
all of a sudden?
Wait a minute. That freaking went
forward. You see that?
What? Why is that happening? I'm stuck
in the habitual way of being. I don't
have enough discipline, control of my
mind to see purely and then to do what
I've seen. I just go right into
autopilot. Okay, got it? So, you have to
step up, dig deeper,
do some mind tricks if you need to. I'm
not doing tension. I'm just doing
this. That's all.
That's all I'm
okay. I'm not going to throw him. I'm
not trying to throw him. Same thing as
I'm not getting ready for
I'm not doing anything. Okay. Have a
pure experience. Okay. Try it again.
need to come up more. You need to move
the center more. No, that's your tension
on him. Move his center past yours.
There you go.
You came. You got uh the palm came off.
Bring it center passing mark center.
Don't come back forward.
More even more passing. Don't come back.
If your hands going west, then there's
no way he's coming forward
more pass. You want to do the full.
You understand? Yes. If you would not
have moved him by going more past,
right, you would have been in yin phase,
but yet he moved, which means you were
still in y face and you just stopped.
What made that a stopping point? Your
ten. Okay. I want you to feel when it
goes into yin phase. Don't want you to
do
I stop. There's a lot of pressure there.
Do you understand? I go here. You'll
feel it come off. You'll feel it come
off. You feel the pressure. Feel the
pressure. It got lighter.
Don't do your freaking thing.
Why would you bend backwards? Why?
Does everyone understand that? Why would
Why would you lean? What in what I am
doing would make you lean backwards.
I'm not coming forward, so you can't say
you're getting out of the way of the
strike.
I didn't push on your head, so you you
can't say I made you go backwards, but
he went right into that stuff. Okay?
You just are a tool.
Okay, even that is too much for me.
Like, what are you afraid of? The little
tap on your face.
Go.
Is there a poo on my elbow or something?
You don't want me to touch your face?
You're going up to come in doing tension
on it.
There's still more
Hi.
Okay, start.
Don't come up right. You'll be going 90
to your own movement.
Are you going to make the edge?
He needs to come in way more.
Don't go up.
Don't go up. Don't go forward. The
movement's coming back.
It doesn't go with your shoulder.
Not your outer deltoid that's moving.
Not my way.
There's this.
That's not where I go.
Okay.
You're going up the energy for yourself.
Use the energy. It will go off on its
own.
Hey, Parker.
Don't come forward.
You could you could let your stance be
moved like I did on you so that I'm not
smashing him in the face. Okay. But
don't come forward. Yes. We don't have
to kill him. Yes.
Now you're using the outer deltoid.
Use the ground.
Outer deltoid. Do you understand what
I'm saying? Yes. Yes. Okay. Can you feel
it? Yes. All right.
Smooth the center
with the ground.
Nope. I know they tell you go up. I know
they're like go up, right?
See people do see people do that stuff,
right? I know that. Okay.
But you're not in the center. Okay. And
he just is trying to go backwards as
soon as he smells that or turn. Okay.
So, we're not doing that
again. And here.
There's the pull. That's That's how we
started the drill. There it is. And I
move that.
That's now going off because I stopped
bouching. Okay. I keep the pressure all
the way and I'm here.
That's not that I'm lifting my arm.
I keep the pressure
there.
If I stop lifting my arm, just like
stopping, you'll feel the pressure will
go off.
You see?
But I'm not just
doing this. are doing this.
Likewise,
yes, he is going to pass me. You see,
but he's not passing me because my arm
goes back.
Nor is he passing me because I turn.
My feet are still I move his center.
Okay. Try
again. Not what we're doing, how we're
doing it. That's what we're doing.
The metric is feel it in your palm.
But you can't let your hand go behind
your shoulder. You can't let your elbow
go behind your shoulder. And you cannot
rotate your waist.
Can't rotate your waist. Can't rotate
your waist. Your elbow can't go behind
your shoulder.
And I can't come forward.
You have to ground that. You're not
grounding it. It's in your shoulder.
Okay, partner.
Ground. You ground them.
Move the center with the friction in the
palm. No, it's coming off.
Keep the friction in the palm.
I can't have my elbow go behind my sp my
shoulder.
I don't come back forward.
Forward, please.
And I can't have my elbow go behind my
shoulder. Right.
It's off. Right. It's off.
I can't stop or it'll go off.
You got to get past me, but my elbow
can't go past me.
Don't use the outer deltoid.
Don't turn your waist. You got the
feeling, but you're turning your waist.
Okay.
Better. Yep. Yep. That's it. Now your
hand.
That was very good.
There's the grounding. Feel the center.
Just keep moving that through the same
mech. Keep moving if you can still move.
There you go.
And then try to do it continuously and
kind of pulse on you. Okay.
Ground that energy. Watch the
reactionary tension.
the restriction.
There you go. Keep it moving as you're
going.
Don't turn on us, Brian. Don't turn on
us.
Walk in.
Round that way. Go back. Ground
yourself. Relax more. Relig
this is coming off because we're pulling
on it. So when you're here like this
pulling on it and then I
stay on it. There's this is that I Stay
on it. Stay on it. Stay on it. Stay on
it. Stay on it.
When you feel that pull,
you would feel the the pressure on the
joints, but you would also feel the loss
of his center when you're when that
happens. Okay.
So, I just doing this
feeling this.
I know it's there. You're like, "Got
you, bitch." Okay, but our drill is
this. I feel this. This looks nothing
like tension right now. Except for I'm
on the inside of his palm and moving
this thing.
Okay, try again.
Y
task yourself with the palm the wrist
connection
and the grounding back in.
Don't walk through.
Okay.
The two hands work
when when I go like this,
the two hands work to inhibit the turn.
So
when this hand is going this way,
it's hard for him to turn. Do you
understand? Just like the spinal
displacement and the occupation, the
occupying of his center of gravity on
the initial assault is hard to turn.
Which is why the only person who can
turn is the person who's not actually
doing the assault. Okay. But this hand
is in there. So again, don't do tenag
can open your grips and make it even
more foreign. But I am now doing the two
of them together. Eventually you'll feel
this one is now lot lighter than that
one. And that is where this goes into
the movement. All I'm not I'm still not
doing tension on it. I'm just
working on this skin phase. Okay. On the
earth hand. So I'm moving him. Got
light. And that's when I move. When I
move, I move around it. It does not move
around me. So as I'm moving,
I'm moving around it.
Okay. So a difference would be my hands
moving around me.
I move around my hand.
All my hand is doing is that. Okay. Make
sure you do the rotations.
One,
two, and it keeps rotating as if you
were going to come back around like
that. Okay. Don't go here. There.
circles.
[Music]
Okay, try
no throws.
No throws. Working on the earth hand.
Keep it moving.
Step around the earth hand, not the
earth hand around you.
So
here don't do anything. Okay. Pull.
Pull. Do the opposite of what they're
telling you. Okay. When I'm here like
this and I move, I don't go here.
Not doing tension. Not here. I'm just
moving him
and keeping this hand effortless.
You see, I'm ignoring this hand.
Okay. So, what am I doing?
The sand goes here.
It needs to go down.
So, I move my body.
You know, my center is moving and I stay
with it.
Then I move inside,
out, in.
Okay.
Out with your hand. In with your hand.
Around your hand.
Out with your hand. You bring your hand
with you. Let it drop. No, don't pull.
Go around your hand. Don't pull.
Then step in
the the quad work is is is right,
Travis, but I want you to leave me
around it.
Out. Step in. You're going to step in
and go around the hand. Pull the hand.
Step in. Don't pull the hand.
So, you're going to go around that hand
one more time. Okay. So, this part here,
this part is great. So, you're shifting
your weight like you need to and then
you're going around the cloth. Perfect.
But this foot
moves around.
You see? So, One, two, three.
Not it goes out and stays out there.
I want to disappear.
Okay, try it again.
Better timing.
Go around it. Don't pull it. Keep it
under your center. Just like the show
work. Where's your power? Underneath
your center.
Don't pull it across your body. Don't
push it away from your body.
You're pulling it away.
Don't pull it away.
Go around it. Go make a circle around
it.
Why is it here? Why can't it be here?
Better.
Don't pull it across your body.
Don't pull. See how he pull See how he
pulls it. Pulling it.
Go around it. Don't pull it. Don't pull
it to your right.
So again like um
right the uh
the institutional understanding is that
you pull you pull the arm and then
eventually he loses his balance. You
know what I'm talking about? So when
when I was first showing this technique,
right, it would and I've still seen it
done this way, right? This move goes
here. They're way freaking back there.
Okay. Um, Sumio To has the same idea.
Like you pull this thing backwards.
Okay. Um,
and you go, it worked. It pulled me off
balance. I did fall. Okay. Why does it
work? Because your feet, you didn't move
your feet. If you keep your feet still
then eventually I'll pull that line of
gravity outside your base support. Got
it? Okay. So now the assumption you
question be what what keeps my feet
still
what's keeping my feet still? No one
ever asks that question. They just feel
yes the the go to the dead
Marshall.
No one goes but why did I keep my feet
still? But you know what the wrestler
does? you.
Okay. And then we have the rope attack.
What the Okay. So, uh
that's why we don't pull.
Okay. We don't want to
um
rely upon their feet being still
and we don't want to contest.
We want to spin the whole body. And in
order to spin the whole body, his feet
actually has to go forward.
They can't stay still. And let alone I
can't pull him backwards. I need him to
keep going forward. Okay, you guys
understand? So, do uh we'll have you do
the
I mean, I know you've done this
technique.
You do some variation of this, right?
Got it. Okay. Only
he goes.
Just move your feet.
Okay. Yeah.
If the punch is coming to your face
parrying it, move your feet.
This we're not doing tension. You're not
holding the other arm. One arm.
Okay. Try uh uh sumo touch. Okay. But
move your feet.
You're going to push on the elbow. You
got to move your feet.
[Music]
Okay.
Some of you were able to uh you know you
I'm pro then and you started doing
something. I'm not sure it's conscious
though.
You started bringing them in. Do you
notice that? So, what are you doing?
What does bringing them in do?
Try to prevent them from going back by
generating more forward momentum. Got
it. I'm occupying their footwork with
the inertia of going forward. Okay. So,
let's try um these two experiments
because not all of you did it. Okay.
do it the way that I demonstrated which
I said this is very common now you do
this so the person enters they don't
bring the person forward the person grab
is not pushing you enter right you go to
the shaku you you me Marshall you
understand
you're here like this this way that's
what you're doing okay try it
and Move your feet again.
Don't go down.
Okay, now bring them in. Got it? You're
going to bring them in
and try to hit it. And you'll see if I
got it, it's because I hit it when their
inertia was going forward. Okay? They're
going to still try to get out of it
because the athlete can adapt to that.
The more athletic you are, the more you
can do. Okay?
So, what are you Noga's bringing them
in? They're not you're not pushing.
They're bringing you in. And then you're
trying to not get thrown by moving your
feet back underneath your line of
gravity. Go.
[Music]
Come on, Andrew.
Okay, so
everyone should have felt man the
pressure freaking increase like crazy
because I'm doing a young young class.
Okay. And again, it'll work if I can
overpower whatever young aspect you
could have. So, we'll have this team go
and you're going to do the same thing
and you see you can get it to work.
See that? But that's not Io first of
all. That has no effect on your
consciousness. And I don't know any any
you know there would be no martial arts
if the tagline was come learn to beat up
people you're way stronger than
you know what I mean? like that wouldn't
have been the selling point. Okay. Um
but if we reverse the roll,
bring them in.
You get this. I can't overcome it. Okay.
Does that make sense? All right. So, my
takeaway here is that
you have to let go like yesterday's
talk. We have to let go
of what we think is functionable.
It's not functioning. It doesn't
function. It functions because my
institutional inertia is fixing my head.
Okay, that's the marshall question.
The other question, the spiritual
question is that's a selfie technique.
This is why
there's so many in our art.
Okay?
We just talk that it's going to teach
humility. We just talk that it's going
to teach surrendering and sacrifice. But
all we do is the same will to power in
all the other arts we claim
are aggressive. You see,
and as I've shared in my experience,
having done those other arts,
there is way more non-contestation
at the higher levels of boxing,
wrestling, BJJ. At the lower levels,
yes. Okay. But you'll start to see at
the higher levels, people start to look
exactly like we know a keto can look
like or should look like. It's just
effortless. You can't. They're like
water. Every time I try to put weight,
they move somewhere else. Every time I
try to hit them in the head, their head
is not there. And now the fist is
hitting my head. You see that? It's all
non-contestation.
What we're battling here is really a UK
culture,
but underneath it is the amount of
control the choreographed UK has.
You see, there's like a silent deal.
Don't make me unself
by giving you control.
Okay,
cool. Don't make me unself by doing
exactly what I want.
Okay? And if you if you just take that
spiritually,
okay,
let me keep control
is a good one. Let me keep control. That
is let me keep power. Let me be power.
Let me have power.
And you take the other one,
right?
Do exactly what I want. Let me have and
keep my desires.
This there's no spirituality in this.
So to undo the culture and the silent
agreement between those two egoic
aspects,
we have to do these things where
we don't generate as much fear because
those are based in fear. Okay?
So hence we use a lot of sui because the
fall is not that high. or we take the
fall off like we are trying to do today.
Okay?
So that the UK does not try to reconcile
anything on their own in any way. Okay?
When we say don't throw them
because we're not trying to fulfill our
desires
and we task ourselves only with just go
around that hand
around that hand.
Don't feel that hand
because that
is not going to work.
And then spiritually it's selfie. Okay.
I'd like to try it a little bit more.
And your your moves
should look like that. Okay. Don't throw
anyone.
Don't do anything again. Okay. All
right.
Go around the hand.
Good.
Don't pull. Go around the hand. Make a
circle.
Bring him bring him to your left first.
Around the head better.
You can hard to bring them forward.
Right?
So at a certain point the hand comes
back
going here at that point is coming back
there until my center is turning
not bring it to my center then step
It already came to my center.
It went from the shoulder line to the
Wuji line and I just keep it there
and I step around it. In
there you go.
Yep. Yep.
Start releasing the tension again. Oops.
came across.
Once it hits the Wuji line, it stays on
the Wuji line, the Earth hand. So once
it hits your spine, stays there. You
have to turn your spine if you needed to
go further.
Oh, you pulled it. All right.
Bring him in care or lean towards him.
Bring him towards you. Good. Go around
that.
Good. So at that at the edge.
So I feel the yin and I say the yin.
The step the size of your step does not
matter.
You see how you are like uh
just do the energy.
That's the yin space. If you feel if you
see him doing this that's the yang
space. Okay.
Take a big entry step.
Yep.
You want to disappear. What's happen?
He has one. All right.
Big step. Big step. There you go.
Big step.
Okay.
We'll see if we get there. But what what
these techniques do and these techniques
are I start at the limb. Okay. And I'm
going to transfer the adhesion to the
That's what this is. Okay.
When you are doing your tension, stop
predicting what I'm doing. Just be.
Okay. Grab. When you are using the arms
to do the throw, you're not doing what
the art is trying to teach you. Transfer
control points from the limbs up to the
spinal what we in call the spinal ring.
Okay. Yeah. We talked about the radius
of the arm. Okay, that's your arm ring,
but there's a spinal ring, too. And uh
that's what this AR this technique is
teaching you. You start out at the arm
ring and you're going to transfer
control point to here. That's why this
arm is not in the technique anymore.
This arm just disappears and you're now
controlling over here.
You understand? Okay. Um, what we all do
instead is that arm is what's pulling
them off balance, but what you're going
to do is stop them going forward.
That's where they can turn. That's where
they get their feedback under you. All
that kind of stuff. Okay. Uh, that's
where we're going with it. All right.
Uh, any questions, comments,
observation? It's it's radically
different. Do you do you see that? So,
one, I don't hang out at the wrist. Two,
I'm not pulling the arms, elbows,
shoulders, and then the line of gravity,
right? And three, I'm not throwing with
both arms.
One arm goes yin, one arm goes young.
Just like in the first the second day of
poke and hole. One arm goes yin, one arm
goes yong. You don't do two young arms.
Okay. Um,
the engine is different. If the engine
is just what's the original
gravitational force, stay with that.
Okay? Not how do I move my arms and
muscles to get this going. Um, okay. So,
there's a lot that are questions,
comments, observations, feelings,
anything. Come on, come closer, please.
I hesitate to ask you
respect
in the exercises that we did with just
the fingertips and a very very light
touch. How come we're not deluding
ourselves? Well, if the UK is not doing
anything and I'm moving them, I don't
know where the delusion would be. unless
I am making more
of that drill. So if when doing that
drill I'm not learning a concept or
principle in a cultivation field and
instead think all I got to do is touch
someone with my fingertips and I will
win the heavyweight title. You see I in
my own mind made that a Marshall
situation and it is not a Marshall
situation. It is an energetic situation.
Okay. So, um once I understand that that
this is not how I fight, this is not
what I do to fight. Okay. And once I
understand that I can do things with my
energetics
for my energetics that I cannot do when
I want to fight. So, for example, on day
one I said form energetically is not
important. Marshall form is very
important. Okay. So already in in the
explanation you realize okay this is not
a application field. This is a
cultivation field. Okay. And I would say
the same thing.
I would just take what you're saying and
apply it to tension.
If you if I grab your wrist, you're not
going to tense up.
It's not going to happen. Okay? But
where were all the diluted questions
on that? You see, or better yet,
the T-Rex arms that no one had a problem
with with two T-Rex arms. Where was the
diluted question there? How did you get
so close?
We seem to be fine with that. You get
it? But I say, "No, no, not." And what
did I say? You guys just aren't hitting
each other enough in your dojo to to not
You should You should see my sons.
This is my sons when they get in that
range because they remember from little
kids they I would smack them. Okay. Um,
go back to the if you pay attention
in the
game.
Some of those kids were harder to get
their back than some of the adults,
okay? Cuz they have more
puditive reps for exposing the back.
Okay?
[Music]
I say I you do need to train
and this is why
I have to make an application field and
I have to make a cultivation field and
that is not problematic as long as I can
identify what's what. Okay. And what I'm
pointing out here is that you you I have
way more cultivation fields and what
you're doing I call that also a
cultivation field but you didn't call it
a cultivation field. Do you see that? So
for that reason I got no problem just
can you feel the inertia? Can you feel
the gravity? Can you feel the friction
now on the arm?
Only the person what I this is what I
found every time.
Only the person who doesn't fight
sees this isn't going to work in a
fight. You know what I mean? And then
they have some other idea that that
that's not fighting either. I tension
grab my wrist.
Um, if you're not quite understanding
me,
every cop who watches the video where
the cop gets grabbed, every cop goes,
"What a idiot."
Okay, that means you up a long
time before you got there.
Um,
I saw this video yesterday.
This cop is obviously not trained well.
He makes contact with a mentally ill
person. The mentally ill person,
lunges at him, cop falls.
He's now being mounted by the mentally
ill person. Doesn't have any skill. Just
assaulted.
Cop can't get him off. He's asking, "Get
off me. Get off me.
Okay,
you he tries to baton him. He has a
piece of crap baton because a lot of
cops do because they never hit people
and they go, "This doesn't work."
Um, same thing with the taser. In the
movies, the taser always works. The
taser never works. I didn't even
I don't even carry one on my belt.
Um,
the that the statistic for a successful
use of the taser is 12%.
Uh so would you would you drive a car
that work 12% of the time? Would you go
on work 12% of the time? Would you buy a
gun that work? You see that taser
everywhere as a crutch? It's like you're
just weighing my back down. Get off. Get
this piece of off me. I'm the
taser.
So cop pulls the ts.
doesn't it doesn't work.
This guy
cannot win this fight.
A real person in real violence would go,
I got to ask. I got to decouple. I got
to get the hell out of here.
What's he do instead? He stays where he
can't win.
And now he
And the guy starts walking towards him.
He shoots him and kills him. Okay. Now,
you might want to be like the way
Hollywood trains us and go, "Well, that
guy could already kick his ass, and so
he needs to shoot him. That's not how
the law works. What was he doing when
you shot him? He was walking."
Well, he was walking toward me. I get
that he's walking toward me, but was he
assaulting you at the moment that you
shot him? No, he was walking towards me.
So, if you want to justify he's walking
towards me and then you go, he could
have assaulted me, then cops could start
shooting everyone who's walking towards
them to go worse than near Starbucks.
You see, and we actually do a training
when I train people, so those that have
remembered,
we have We put the cop with a hood on
their face and we put a square of cones
on the mat and we say, "Your environment
is only what's inside the cones." We
walk them into the cones. Um, the first
scenario when we pull the hood off, the
guy has a gun visible in their holster.
They're not walking or anything. In
fact, they'll smile at you. Okay? And
you'll see the recruits will go, "Oh,
he's smiling. He must not want to kill
me." And so then they go like, "Oh, sir,
was that a gun in your waistband? Is
there a reason for that gun?" Instead of
looking at, "What's the tactical
problem?" The tactical problem is he's
got a gun. You see, it's against the law
to carry that gun in the state of
California and open carry. So, you're
going to have to detain him. You got to
detain him at the level of the presence
of the weapon.
They always f it up. There's very few
people that come in. This is how that
scenario goes. Hey, get on the ground.
Oh, I have it. I don't care. Turn
around. Get on the ground. My name is I
don't get this. Get on the ground. Take
care of the tactical situation. Then the
investigation happens. Then the next
scenario we do Same thing. We don't
brief them on what you should do. We
just watch them. Okay. Next one we do,
hood comes off. Guy's still smiling at
you. He's not the gun. And he just
shoots you. Boom. Shoots you dead.
Now they're like, I was like, I
up the first one. I up. You got
it. And now the third one comes. Guy's
still there. Same guy, dressed exactly
the same. Hood's on their head. Hood
comes off. He walks towards you. Hey
officer, do you know where you see how
many people draw down on that dude?
Shoot that dude. Okay. And he was about
to say you know where Starbucks is.
Okay.
So anyone that shoots that guy that that
was on proportional force that's illegal
force.
Yes, your situation is getting worse as
you're going on, right? But you have to
adapt to what is happening there. Okay.
And I would say that before you grab me,
for some weird reason, I have my hands
in space in the same place as if I was
handcuffed.
I should have done a lot more by the
time you got there. And I, this is what
I always tell the cops. I train. Well, I
I I
hate to say it, but if you got your self
grabbed, take the be. you got to
come and work from it because he's
really effed up. So this cop shoots that
guy and he's going to prison. There's no
way around in his head. He's thinking
all these things but they're not
realistic. Not realistic.
Likewise,
I should have done a hell of a lot more.
You would have such a hard time grabbing
both wrists,
but We're totally fine with that,
right? Or we're totally fine with that
version that's everywhere.
It didn't work.
So, I would just extend I think you're
on the right track, but recognize
my caveat here would be make a clear
distinction between what's a cultivation
field, what's an application field.
Um, and in the in the uh Patreon group,
we have that long thread where
um one of the highlights is the video of
Ronin and it's all mixing and matching.
And I guarantee you there's a lot of
people who go, "That's not Aido. That's
MMA." You see? But what happens when the
MMA fighters fight him? He's elusive. as
Okay. U because of the
non-contestation.
I shared that one video of that guy that
was doing iikido. Uh you remember that
it was like a Asian guy and he would
just constantly elude what was going
that part is the iikido but
the eo that's not the iikido. That's the
energetic exercise. That's not the
self-defense thing. Um, and you saw him
do the yin yields and the disengagements
and the decoupling and then boom, right?
And that's how we fight with this art.
We don't fight with chemo because chemo
was our cultivation.
So now if we understand that and we go,
are we diluting ourselves from what I'm
feeling or pressing? Again, make sure
you're doing nothing. Don't do anything.
Don't forward.
Notice what I did at a certain point
with the UK that kept coming forward.
You see, I made them do the opposite of
what would led to the technique. Okay?
To let them know
you should not be needing their
cooperation. I'm going to make you do
the counter to the technique. Okay.
Um,
I don't know how, you know, I could
imagine that someone's doing the
fingertip pressure and then the the UK
is like moving forward. You know what I
mean? I guess that could happen, but you
as the Nugget cannot tell that they
moved themselves. That could happen. Um,
I don't I don't see a way out of that.
But I wouldn't call that delusion. I
would call that ignorance. I can't tell
that you moved yourself. Okay. Okay. My
solution was I can tell I didn't move
you. So, I'm going to make you go the
opposite way. So, you stop moving
yourself to help me. Even on this last
one
before we even started, I could already
tell his body was trying to effing help
me. And you heard me go
right.
You can see the lid of my face.
Okay. Right. So you Yeah. Hold yourself
accountable. Um and what I would say
then is if you can't feel it, then don't
think you're doing it. It's it's a real
feeling and you can feel it. Okay. If
you can't feel it, it's like I can't
tell. That's where you land instead of
I'm doing it. Okay. Or hey, try to pull
away from me. Let me see if I can do it.
But going to be harder to do that. So,
all right. But good question.
Um, on that note, I mean, what did you
what did you I did touch hands with you
guys. What did did you feel it or were
you like I don't feel it and I'm like,
"Oh, I feel it." Do do you know what I
mean?
Come on. I touch with you with with you
guys. What did What did What did it feel
like? What's happening?
Come on. I know. We went We went
we went. What's it feel like
to me? Um, I recognized that my
shoulders were getting tired. So, I
could feel this seizure within my
shoulders. And then as you were doing
it, um, it it comes from underneath. So,
it's it's not a over the top, you know,
it comes from underneath. And you could
at a certain point it was just
everywhere. Um, Yeah, it's
hard to explain completely, but like it
does feel like a seizure of the center.
And so again, the seizure is my poetics.
Like I I don't know. I told you if you
when you push when you push me to
explain this, I ended up saying
y
the universe goes the same. And bird is
saying that I took I don't know why it
happens. It just happens. Okay. So
that's why I use the phrase poetics. And
if I take his poetics like it feels like
it's coming from underneath,
I would say it's it's not in the
shoulders. It's down in the center.
That's why it feels like it's coming
from underneath because usually they're
in our shoulders because they're in our
arms trying to move our arms. Do you see
that? Uh, if he never had the arm
experience, he wouldn't have said from
underneath.
Maybe he said in the middle. Do you get
that? So, I I can hear his poet go,
"Yeah, that that is making sense, but
only because I know what it feels like."
He knows what it feels like and I can go
that's he's talking about the same
thing. So, no different from I've been
in love. I read a poem about love. It's
not even talking about love, but I know
exactly what this is talking about
because I had that feeling. I don't have
that. I've never been in love. I have no
idea. Like that joke the joke yesterday
like tell your tell your spouse to calm
down in a fight. Okay, you're I tell
that to Tristan. He's going to go okay.
But all of us go, "No, don't do
that." Right? Because we've been there.
So, we have the feeling because we have
the experience of it. If you don't have
the feeling or you don't have the
experience, then I would say I don't
know. Okay. I wouldn't go it's
or something like that. Okay. Um but
okay, that that's a very good way of
explaining it. Someone else, you might
have different poetics. Um it feels like
to me when when the communion happens
that you or
it becomes like a third balance point
for me and so I rely on that and then
when it moves I have to I I can see that
um
and I hear that one a lot so to me that
makes sense because I know what's
happening especially when I did it with
you because I wanted you to I wanted it
to be so subtle on you. Uh if you
remember when I was going with him, I
would barely move it and at a certain
point I would just it's there and I'm
not even moving it but he could tell
okay that it was there. Um
and to me when that happened though,
are you really leaning on me for
balance?
Not even say no. Can I move you so that
you do lean on me for balance? Yes, that
that can happen. Okay. Uh and the reason
why I wanted to draw that distinction is
because a lot of regular iikido is get
that guy leaning on you. Okay. But
that's not the same thing as I I have
your center. We're not even moving and I
I have your center. Okay. Yeah. But I
would say not so much on a phys
Yeah. But more good. When you're
standing, you're not leaning on
anything, but the ground. So, it's more
it's like a I I just noticed that for
myself, you always are adjusting your
balance on some level. Yes. To what's
around you. Y. And so, when we're when
we're making that connection, there's
there's almost like
you could call it an energetic tether. I
But it's like I'm using you as a means
to orient myself. Not on a physical
level so much, although there's physical
touch. It's it's subtle. Like it's if
it's physical, it's very very subtle.
Okay. So now now I go Yeah. Now that
that is it. So I'll point you to
something. Remember uh the video of
Seafo Seafood Nico
and how he's doing push hands versus how
everyone else does push hands. He just
catches them at the at the very source,
right? And then they're moving. So you
when I watch him, I know he can push,
but he won't because that's not what
he's trying to do here. So he he either
gets it he either gets you to fall like
with these kind of little movements,
just adjusting up, or he won't try and
he'll let you push him out or he starts
all over. He goes totally in and then
seeks a contact again. Okay. So yeah, I
do I do agree. And so I would as as you
and here's why the constant adapting of
my b balance here but I would say it's
the constant adapting to the yong
aspect. So because as you seize the
center the person does something and you
have to keep the feeling and to keep the
feeling you can't be be doing the same
thing because the situation change. So
there is this kind of like uh yeah we're
in this constant state um where we're
it's kind of like that you know what I
mean um
and again that is just a cultivation
field marshially it has to be done right
away. So in other words right when I
have the center like we did yesterday
you're in and The inertia has you and
now by the time you figure it out
whatever you're already flipping through
space you see that. So this is why I say
more the adhesions in a cultivation
field or the energetics in cultivation
field you want to prolong them and you
want them to be very subtle because that
increases skill. But marshally we're
talking hundreds of a second and just
pure freaking force. Okay? And um not
not
This is go back. This is one of my huge
disagreements with the with the uh
heaven man earth thing because they they
think they're going to keep that going
for forever. Like that's okay. That's
good training. That's a good cultivation
field. But that's not how it happens.
Okay. It happens like yesterday. Boom.
You're you're in it and now I'm done.
The technique is gone. Okay.
Um but good you could You could feel
that very good. And other ones that were
added,
when it's not on, I feel like my mind
can kind of find places to release, but
then when it goes on,
the feeling doesn't really change, but
then things just start
it almost feels like picture like a
cartoon. There's like a laser gun that
like picks things up and moves them.
It's a whole thing instead of
causing
yes I I agree the linking that there's
no linking everything just starts moving
um
so I now have some feeling and that's
what I should feel for if I don't have
this
you know tracker beam feeling or this
constant I got to stay and and keep
moving and keep the same feeling Right.
Um
or I don't I'm up in the shoulders. I
feel it in my shoulders. I don't feel it
in my center. Then I'm not doing it. And
if I say I am even though I feel I'm
doing something else, then I am deluding
myself. Does that make sense?